Now, what if we want both
confidentiality and integrity?
How about we encrypt the message and
send all the CBC blocks, and
that's the ciphertext blocks for
protecting confidentiality.
And then, we'll replicate the last
block, which is a CBC residue, and
that's for integrity.
Would that work?
Obviously this approach does not work
because if we simply replicate the last
block, we are not adding anything.
That is, we are not doing anything
in addition to protecting
the confidentiality.
Therefore there is no way this
approach will work to provide both,
confidentiality and integrity.
We can instead use two different keys.
One for producing CBC blocks for
confidentiality, and
the other for generating the residue for
integrity, that is we encrypt
twice using two different keys.
Another approach is that we first
compute a hash of the message.
Appended it to the message and
then encrypt the whole entity.